Це - найбільша лікарня у Німеччині,
клініка Мюнхенського університету.
Гігантський комплекс зі штатом у 10 тисяч осіб
та майже 2,5 тисячами ліжкомісць.
Утім, німецький пацієнт зазвичай скористатися послугами
лікарні-велетня якщо і зможе,
то не одразу. Ось чому.
У разі хвороби в Німеччині спочатку звертаються до сімейних лікарів.
Вони працюють у приватних лікарських практиках.
Сімейний лікар встановлює перший діагноз
і або надає всю необхідну допомогу пацієнту,
або ж скеровує його до вузькопрофільних спеціалістів.
До іншого лікаря, наприклад, кардіолога.
Або до великої лікарні
на кшталт тієї, що у Мюнхені.
Університетські клініки -
це поліклініки широкого профілю,
де проводять найскладніші операції.
Сюди в разі сумнівів у поставленому вам діагнозі
можна звернутися за альтернативною думкою.
Сімейні лікарі на вихідних не працюють,
і у термінових випадках пацієнти також звертаються
до відділень швидкої допомоги,
які відкриті цілодобово.
У Німеччині, за офіційними даними -
1942 лікарні.
З кожним роком їх меншає,
але водночас наявні лікарні
збільшуються в розмірах
та розширюють спектр своїх послуг.
Кількість лікарів щороку зростає.
Нині їх 385 тисяч.
Крім того, у Німеччині
102 тисячі сімейних лікарів.
Слід зауважити, що лікарням у Німеччині
гостро бракує персоналу.
Фахівці оцінюють цю потребу
в 50 тисяч додаткових лікарів.
У розпорядженні німецьких клінік
є майже 500 тисяч ліжкомісць,
у тому числі 28 тисяч ліжкомісць
інтенсивної терапії.
Технічне устаткування німецьких клінік -
на висоті.
Щороку лікарні в Німеччині купують медичне обладнання
в середньому на понад 35 мільярдів євро.
У порівнянні з іншими європейськими країнами, у Німеччині
лише найбільше ліжкомісць на тисячу мешканців,
а й кількість клінік доволі висока.
40 лікарень на мільйон мешканців.
Це удвічі більше, ніж у США.
Є ще один яскравий статистичний показник: близько 96% населення
можуть дістатися до найближчої лікарні
менше ніж за 20 хвилин.
Понад третина лікарень у Німеччині  - 37% - мають приватних власників.
29% лікарень перебувають у власності громад і земель.
Решта належать спілкам та організаціям, зокрема й церковним
Купувати ліки в аптеках власним коштом хворим
у Німеччині здебільшого не потрібно.
Те, що прописує лікар, за деякими винятками,
оплачує каса медичного страхування.
Також страхування фінансує послуги лікарів, усі витратні матеріали,
перебування й харчування в лікарні.
І звичайно, роботу лікарів.
За рік каси медстрахування переказують лікарням
225 мільярдів євро.
І лише невелика частка в фінансуванні лікарень -
3 мільярди євро - це бюджетні кошти.
Критики кажуть, що чинна система фактично стимулює клініки
ганятися за кількістю пацієнтів,
економлячи на персоналі.
Адже страхова каса платить лікарні за пацієнта
певну суму - залежно від діагнозу та терапії.
Вона визначена у тарифному каталозі.
Тобто спрацьовує принцип "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом",
який передбачає і медреформа в Україні.
Ось як виглядає "тарифний каталог":
Наприклад, одна з найдешевших операцій -
лікування легких опіків, один день у лікарні.
625 євро.
А ось найдорожчі операції:
ШВЛ понад 999 годин,
трансплантація печінки, легенів, серця та кісткового мозку
або пересадка стовбурових клітин.
Кошторис - 179 тисяч євро.
У Німеччині, як і в Україні, триває запекла дискусія
про доцільність медреформи.
Держава прагне розбудувати вузьку спеціалізацію лікарень.
Адже, на думку деяких експертів,
якість операцій краща саме там, де проводять
багато однотипних операцій,
а зазвичай у Німеччині багато оперують у лікарнях широкого профілю.
Зворотний бік медалі - окремим лікарням
у маленьких містечках
загрожує закриття, і це обурює місцевих мешканців.